haha we're back to talk about more anime
fights baby
and yes this video was again kindly
sponsored and improved by oasis games
and naruto online yes that's right
naruto online came back to sponsor
another video about anime fights
it's a free to play naruto mmo which i
will be talking about in more depth
later
but for now you can sign up in the link
in the description and with that intro
done
let's get to it
we just can't get enough can we there's
no way i could ever cover
everything i wanted to talk about and of
course everything you wanted to hear
about anime fights in just one video so
here we go again
let's talk about and analyze five more
fights in anime and break down how they
can make a fight work
this of course is not a ranked top list
but just ways to highlight some elements
of a good fight scene and show you why
they
are good so get your linkin park top 10
watch mojo anime fight scenes out of
here cause this is what we're gonna be
doing today
hold up guys hold up i know we're using
this song now
but we're not going to be covering any
jojo's fights in this video
oh come on guys not everything in the
world can revolve around jojo's
let's start things off by talking about
one of the most romanticized objects in
the entertainment media
guns there is nothing cooler than a good
gun fight and this is no exception in
anime but many of the best shootouts i
can think of are dangerously close to
just being a straight up action scene
rather than a fight scene
which i can and probably will dedicate a
whole other video to
so i decided to limit this to just
one-on-one gun jewels of which there are
still plenty of great examples trigon
and cowboy bebop have many classic
shootouts kanan was quite overlooked
even though he had many great gun fights
and gile versus odusaku from bungo stray
dogs was all sorts of badass
but ironically enough the coolest
gunfight i've seen in recent memory
isn't even from a gun centric or
action-oriented anime but is of course
mummy vs homura from madoka 3 rebellion
[Applause]
as i said before there is nothing cooler
than a good gunfight so how do we make
that even more fun
well you added elements you wouldn't
normally see in one like time violation
powers
magical girls gun foo striking visuals
and it's these blending of elements that
makes this fight
work so well it's nothing like your
usual realistic gun battle that revolves
around tactical positioning cover and
aim but its goal is just to give you a
fun time marveling at all these
ridiculous elements you are seeing on
screen
neither side seems to have much more
tactics aside from just spray and prey
with enough rough aiming to make a
[ __ ] stormtrooper crowd but when
you're seeing things like bullets
colliding in midair sparking up the
background
enough bullet streaks stopped in time to
make dio brando feel inadequate
airborne acrobatic gunplay and of course
not forgetting seeing [ __ ] magical
girls in a gun battle
who the hell really cares it's these
individual components you don't normally
see together that allows us to just
marvel at the spectacle
every stage they bring in something new
and interesting to add to the mix from
homura just pulling out bigger and more
powerful guns up her ass
even gun cutter which if you did know is
a fictional close quarters gun play
resembling martial arts
that probably would be really stupid and
impractical if ever attempted in real
life but it just looks really [ __ ]
cool
so what do they do to one up that
element how about gun cutter in mid
[ __ ] air alright it's the kind of
fast-paced unrealistic action do you see
from watching gameplay of bayonetta or
dev may cry that tries nothing more but
to bring you gratuitous gun action that
you can't help but just sit back and be
amazed by
and finally on top of all that you have
that satisfying moment when time
unpauses
and all those hundreds of bullets frozen
in the streams go flying everywhere
overall this fight shows us how to blend
many cool elements into a single fight
that you can only see in something like
anime
for non-action oriented show it delivers
one of the best fight scenes anime has
to offer and from a series perspective
it was a treat
to finally see what mami can do when she
actually has her [ __ ] head in the
game
[Music]
okay you don't need to say it i'll do it
myself
there's a lot more to what defines the
battle beyond simply fighting and a
genre that's always given an interesting
dynamic to this concept is in sports
anime even if these aren't fights in the
traditional sense they are a combat of
skill and can often get us way more
hyped than their traditional
counterparts cena and shin's final
showdown in isil 21 was the ultimate
culmination of 150 episodes worth of
rivalry and all of kagami and aluminum's
clashes in kuroko were nothing short of
super saiyan basketball spectacular but
if we're talking the greatest battle in
sports anime and one that takes all the
boxes of what makes a traditional fight
brilliant at that it could only be
takamura vs brian hawke from hajime no
ippo
one of the many things that ippo has
always stood out for among its peers is
just how much passion and heart goes
into the motivations of its characters
in any given fight it always feels like
there's something huge on the line not
only for both competitors in the ring
but every single spectator outside of it
as well
it's this backbone that makes every
single punch every new technique and
every drop of blood spilled holds
narrative weights beyond the fact that
it's just
[ __ ] hype as [ __ ] isn't it how it
continually does this and why it still
manages to work after well over a
thousand chapters is because of the way
it actually mirrors its real life
professional sports rather than just
showing a group of guys having a gay old
time getting to nationals when you look
at real life sports you have an ongoing
narrative that naturally forms
filled with larger than life characters
and it's this natural storytelling that
makes sports like mma unboxing as
interesting as the sport itself
especially in contact sports
people buy into the personalities and
natural charisma of the competitors this
is why someone like conor mcgregor
is as popular as he is if you watch an
outspoken personality
one who refuses to be ignored talks a
big game and then backs it up by winning
in other words he's a bit of a [ __ ] but
it's characters like this that draws ice
the product
gets pay-per-view buys and keeps you
coming back for more
then there is a man like floyd
mayweather who has a story as simple as
you can get of a man who is undefeated
and so
fight after fight people will chew it in
just to see if he will finally receive
that first loss which is why even in his
own anime i feel like ippo is far less
interesting a character to watch than
takamura as you can see all these
elements come into play in this fight
both competitors are both undefeated
going into it they both have very wild
confident personalities and have very
clear motivations for winning we may
have only known hawke for a few episodes
but he's been built up well as the
natural antagonist in all this as we all
want to see him lose and the press
conference drama only serves to
immensely hype us up before the match
even starts
it's a far cry from your traditional
modern sports anime as the stage feels
much grander and we don't have to worry
about
yowie tension in between either because
god these characters are [ __ ] ugly by
the time the fight happens we already
feel the energy of the crowd and in turn
know exactly why they want to see
takamura take the belt but through
internal dialogue and being much closer
to these characters than it's possible
to be in reality
it's all taken a step beyond and ramped
up to the nth degree we see the immense
struggle that takamura had to go through
just to get
this fight his relationship with his
coach and his desire to prove his
orthodox style on the world stage
we know how much this means for him this
is why every blow exchanged on stage has
a tremendous amount of weight behind it
and i'm not talking about the physical
force the punches mean
something and relates to how each of the
characters has been presented throughout
the fight we see a mix of methodologies
intelligent tactics raw aggression from
both sides and eventually pure fighting
spirit once it feels as though both
fighters have burned through everything
they have
ippo and this fight in particular is a
masterclass on how to hype us up for a
fight how to get us invested in every
punch thrown and how to absolutely
deliver through with that hype
building up to one final punch that puts
a full stop to not only the fight itself
but the incredible journey we've watched
takamiro undertake as a character that
you can't help but just jump up and
shout
[ __ ] yes
now if there's one fight dynamic that's
easy to completely [ __ ] up it's battles
that involve one individual against a
large group or army
nothing says badass like one man taking
on a group of people and when it's done
well it can be a spectacle like no other
and often works towards defining the
strengths of the character in question
in anime and manga terms many would
agree that the most iconic instance of a
fight like this would be the clash
between guts versus 100 knights
but unfortunately due to berserk have
never gotten the adaptation it truly
deserves
this scene falls short technically in
both anime and while there have been
many good little examples scattered all
over anime
one punch man sword of a stranger afro
samurai
if there is one fighting anime that
truly captures how to make a character
feel like they are a one-man army and
does so with pure class and style we
again look towards naruto shipuden in
maduro uchiha versus the allied shinobi
forces
[Music]
now the key to keeping a fight of this
kind interesting is by making it feel as
though the individual in question is
legitimately a level beyond the
adversaries because in reality you can't
have one man fight hand-to-hand
hundreds of enemies at once unless he
was a [ __ ] centipede so in fiction
particularly in old kung fu movies the
technique to make it feel as though one
fighter can take on a large group
single-handedly often revolves around
the manipulation of background
characters the main fighter in question
will only be interacting with a maximum
of one or two people
at once per rotation but through having
so many other characters in the
background moving in and out of shot the
illusion is created of an unstoppable
badass who can take down an army in this
fight the most impressive and
captivating sequences are the ones in
which madara is engaging in hand-hand
combat early on
now there is a few ways to choreograph a
fight like this but if you look at some
of the best martial arts scenes of this
type you can see that there is a certain
rhythm to the movements
one action flows from one movement to
another then to another and then to
another which makes sense in context
because the one person fighting has to
dispatch each opponent as quickly and
efficiently as possible
what this does is showcases free-flowing
combat that not only emphasizes the
skill gap for that one person but also
looks really [ __ ] cool and you can
see this play out with the way madora
dispatches his opponents always flowing
with the momentum of his movements
along with the efficiency of each attack
from the use of the explosive paper to
the arm breaks to the swordplay
the speed and fluidity is what makes
this work but the advantage it has over
normal martial arts films that it can
incorporate superpowers with the
choreography without making it look
stupid
see if he had some kind of superpower
element in live action it can come off
as kind of cartoonish which is fine if
you're going for a light-hearted silly
tone as seen here in kung fu hustle but
played off seriously it just looks
ridiculous
the minor reflex can get away with
playing this office totally serious
without having it look out of place
cheesy or cartoonish because
well it's a [ __ ] cartoon
allowing him to do things like leap
across the battlefield dispatching every
opponent in his path like he's the
murderous [ __ ] beyblade
the reason this fight stands above all
others of his kind and anime is because
of the way it blends in genuine martial
arts choreography with anime superpowers
and does it stylishly and you may think
that i love talking about naruto fights
a bit too much but it's because the
series genuinely has some of the best
executed fight scenes in anime on a
technical level but not at the cost
overall the animation quality of the
series can be largely inconsistent since
studio period seems to have the sound
tactic of basically using their entire
year's resources on a single episode
leading to fights like these with
beautiful sequences like seeing a ninja
skillfully dispatching his opponents in
a cloud of steam with his fireballs
raining down from the sky
this fight was meant to build madara up
as a big final boss villain and i'm glad
the sequence showcased some of his more
intimate fighting skills rather than
just going straight for the cheap
overpowered abilities like casually
dropping the odd meteor on the bloody
battlefield but seeing as the opening of
this fight has some of the most slick
and fluid choreography we've seen in an
anime fight
it does well overall in showing that
naruto really does know how to present a
final villain
now that all said and done this is the
time i get to talk about the sponsor for
this video and we've done this before so
no [ __ ] this time
let's get down to it if i've not made it
abundantly clear so far there are a lot
of moments in naruto that i genuinely
love from the original and shipped and
playing through naruto online allows me
to relive some of those favorite moments
when i was just a kid getting into anime
along with some of my favorite fights
from the franchise it's a free-to-play
mmo browser game that's officially
licensed which you can definitely tell
by the surprising production values it
has for a browser game
you play through the original naruto
story with an original character and
along the way meets all your favorite
characters who can become part of your
ninja dream team crap hold on a second
who can become part of your ninja dream
team though there is more depth than
just using characters you like i've
talked about this before so this time i
got my editor to try out and he enjoyed
it enough that he got further than i did
last time so we could show off some more
of the features and characters that show
up oh
10 10 everyone's favorite ninja ever
how's the screen time treating you if
this sounds interesting to you you can
sign up and try the game for free by
clicking on the link in the description
because i think it's pretty great that
we can get sponsored to talk about
something we love
anime fights so if anything i think
that's worth a chance but speaking of
anime fights let's get back on that
topic
moving on i'm sure i'm not alone in
saying that one of the first things i
think of when it comes to fights in
anime
is the use of super powers and power
systems in general a good power system
can add a layer of depth to a fight and
make even
the simplest of brawls more interesting
and there have been plenty of examples
of that in anime chakra from naruto was
i'm sure many of our first introduction
to a proper power system
devil fruits and one piece gave us a
wide array of weird abilities that are
dear to real world traits whereas stans
and jojo's prove there is really no
limit to how imaginative and out there a
character's ability can be
but to me there is no power system that
truly captures the brilliance of variety
and spectacle while still complying by
its own strict set of rules better than
men from hunter x hunter and while i
might be cheating a bit by not actually
talking about one particular fight scene
i wanted to take this opportunity to
talk about how
and why a well-thought-out power system
enhances a fight for a power system that
throughout the series produces such an
expansive array of very weird
complicated and wild abilities it's
always amazed me how it never once
didn't make sense
men are so strictly defined and well
explains that even the most powerful
techniques in later arcs still abide by
the rules laid out at its inception and
every ability no matter how complicated
can be logically deducted from these
building blocks it's a system of classes
each with their own clearly defined
strengths and weaknesses that works
almost like a competitive video game as
no one ability is too powerful or cannot
be counted
to me it does wonders knowing that even
the most seemingly overpowered
characters have legitimate strategy that
can be used to counter them and it's
less of a case of if a counter strategy
exists and more of a question of if the
strategy can be successfully executed
it's almost as if tagashi himself wasted
countless hours being able to play rpgs
to be able to come up with the system as
balanced and intricate as this but who
knows where you'd get the time to do
that eh what this can do is add a layer
of complexity to a fight while still
making it a spectacle think of it like
watching a competitive video game it's a
sight to watch the mechanical skills of
the top players in the world and watch
them do things you didn't even know was
possible but what sets apart the best
players aren't just mechanical skill but
also
game knowledge having a good grasp of
the system you are playing in means that
you can deduce your opponent's strategy
and move to counter it
and part of the spectacle if you're
familiar with the game they are playing
is understanding the meta game going on
while also being able to see the
strategy be executed and this is the
exact feeling you get when watching a
nen battle in the world of hunter x
hunter having strong fighting skills is
as important as having an understanding
of how nen works and you can see this
balance when the top level fighters do
battle when in vogue battles karapika
for example
even though his powers are as simple and
cliche as a power can get he's super
strong and can punch things really hard
he still uses his head and doesn't only
rely on his strengths
he has a keen battle sense and uses his
wit to try to deduce the true nature of
his opponent's abilities to try and find
any weaknesses he can exploit
a person's knowledge of their opponents
and then ability can make or break a
fight which is why for as strong as
uvagin was and even though he's
far from stupid he still gets absolutely
decimated
it's all about advantages krapika's
abilities were specifically home to take
down him and his group and has taken
huge preparations to ensure his victory
from an outsider perspective it may seem
like karapika is stupidly overpowered
but in the context of the fight he's
only truly overpowered in this exact
scenario and in many series would feel
like a genuine ass pool but because of
what we know about
nen and karapaka's history it makes
perfect sense think about an ability
like killer queen bites the dust from
diamond is unbreakable it's only useful
in the exact scenario it happens in and
it happens seemingly out of nowhere
it just works but the technique kuropka
uses in this fight very much abides by
the rule of nem
he's created this ability for the sole
purpose of dealing with uvergan in his
group whom we know kuropa has been
plotting revenge against since episode
1.
he does so through a very specific set
of limitations which if found out could
be disastrously exploited and the way it
works is a master class and how you make
an overpowered ability without
technically being overpowered this fight
is just one of many that makes nen such
an
interesting system to explore so let's
give tagashi a big round of applause for
coming up with such a system
[Applause]
oh you know we can just do that
moving on mecca as a genre has always
had a long history of relying on the who
has the biggest gun contest of resolving
conflict and it's this that makes a lot
of the best fights in mecca fall down to
the interesting tactical decisions and
character interactions to make them
stand out there are surprisingly few
great mecha fights out there that
operate as a battle of technology with
the specs of the machine genuinely
adding to the action instead of taking
away from it
hey remember that time when [ __ ] off
energy wings took over tactics and code
geass because i know i do
shows like the original sdf mark ross
erecka 7 and a lot of the universal
sentry gundam however integrate their
technology into conflict incredibly well
and a fantastic example of a battle that
shows exactly how technology should be
used to enhance the viewer experience
would be the penultimate showdown of the
full armor gundam and psyko zaku in
gundam thunderbolt
i've done them as a franchise has always
fully utilized the historical
implications of how great an effect the
advancements in weapons technology have
on the outcome of war particularly with
how deep gundam's law goes in regards to
mobile suit technology development with
the xeon and earth federation having a
constant dick measuring contest
and coming from an engineering
background myself seeing the development
and conflict of fictitious technologies
in meccas does
wonders in stroking the engineering
boner in me
[Music]
so as good as the stories behind the
pilots are in this fight i wanted to
focus purely on the mobile suits and
their technology and how it's used in
this battle
on one side we have the fa 78 full armor
gundam a mobile suit that out of context
looks pretty over the top and ridiculous
but these shields heavy armor and
propellant tanks are all there with the
purpose of safely navigating and
engaging in battle within the dangerous
asteroid field terrain of the
thunderbolt sector and on the other side
of the battlefield you have the xeon
developed ms-06r
psykozaku a similarly ridiculous looking
mobile suit specked for super high
mobility above all else
and does this at the cost of an arm and
leg
no seriously only quadruple amputees can
pilot this thing just by looking at the
designs of both suits you can see the
technology pissing match they are having
with each other because they just look
they just look
technology and over the course of the
battle we see every single seemingly
impractical peripheral of each machine
used making it clear to the viewer that
they aren't simply there for aesthetics
alone from the very destructive force of
their main weaponry
to the ridiculous speeds at which luzaku
enters the battlefield with the large
propellant boosters on its back the
gundam's extra shield are shown to allow
to attack whilst defending
simultaneously whilst the wide array of
thrusters that cover the legs and
backpack of the zaku allow it to
seamlessly weave and dodge around enemy
fire with the simple established fact
that it's only able to deliver such
precise control because of the machine's
inhumane control system one of the
greatest things this battle shows is
that when it comes down to mechanical
design in science fiction
functionality is paramount and as
opposed to a clash of fighting styles
you see in a traditional fight it's
actually a clash of design philosophy
but it also never ignores the basic
principles you need to consider when in
a fight
from the way the buildings are used as
cover to the full armor using the grip
on his feet for a surprising turnaround
to the t-shirt that lands on the zaku
blocking visibility
it's these little details that sell the
idea that even when piloting these
mechanical beasts with technology far
beyond our understanding it still takes
skill and thought to win a fight
and not just you know [ __ ] spamming
energy beams in every conceivable
direction as the battle draws to a close
whilst technology is what made this
fight stand out to me it's the story
behind the pilots that leave such a
resonating impression in the finale with
azaku rendered inactive and a credible
sequence of static electricity from a
kiss in a flashback sequence from one of
the pilots transitions into
a thunderbolt that lacerates the
battlefield shocking the zaku's circuits
back into action and with his final
collision
draws the battle to a close i don't
understand
why the hell can't i beat him
i understand now carla getting to meet
you like this
that was my miracle
[Music]
now aside from super powers samurai and
giant robots what's the one thing that
japanese media is known for by
mainstream
culture that's right monsters titanic
organic creatures doing battle causing
the casual earthquake which have been an
iconic part of japanese culture since
godzilla came out of the country in the
50s but for as iconic as this is there
surprisingly
isn't so many giant monster anime to
choose from rastafari certainly takes
the cake for the most emotional monster
battle to ever be put on screen
the titan fights an attack on titan was
a literal wild and intense clash of
titans but if we're going to be talking
about giant monster fights there is one
scene that still stands to this day
as one of the most iconic scenes to ever
come out of anime and that is of course
oscar versus the ava series from end of
evangelion
okay okay i know these are technically
mechs but with the organic design and
characteristics of the avers this fight
plays out far less like automated
machines doing battle and more like a
fight between
kaiju from the way the ava series begin
by ominously flying in a circle like
vultures ready to pick apart their prey
to the signature detailed environmental
damage that is present in any kaiju
fight to the beautiful violence and
grotesque way that the fight ends that
sells the animalistic vibe
it's a great example of visual
storytelling which combined with bucks
air playing in the background gives off
the vibe
this is a prolonged funeral procession
more than a fight and that's exactly
what it's meant to represent
ask his last stand but what this fight
does better than any other anime fight
before or after
it is how well it sells the idea that
these are titanic beings wrecking an
entire landscape see the problem with a
lot of fights involving giant robots and
monsters is that they just don't feel
well giant if you sit back and actually
think about how a skyscraper would move
if it had a pair of legs
even the simplest of movements would
take a lot of effort as there is so much
weight behind it but you don't see this
with the agile movements in a lot of
giant robot fights and the illusion that
they are gargantuan beasts are lost when
they are effortlessly performing hyper
speed 360 no scope acrobatics like
they're auditioning for season 2 of yuri
on ice
on speed even if it can look cool
[Music]
i'm on an example of something that
shows this well is in pacific rim
which shouldn't be surprising consider
how similar the concepts are to
evangelion and might have even gotten
inspiration from this scene
part of the reason these fights feel
larger than life is because everything
about them
feels massive every movement is slow and
deliberate the wind wind-up to every
punch feels like an eternity compared to
a normal one but what this does is give
the thing a sense of mass
there's momentum there's force and most
importantly there's weight behind
every blow a literal [ __ ] ton of it
which is exactly what you'd expect when
you're watching two skyscrapers playing
a game of fisticuffs against each other
all these elements are quite clearly
evident in the fight
the slow detailed movement the way she
wrestles against the momentum of the ava
and the monumental force behind every
blow
these look feel and move like giant
robots should and just because of the
pacing of the movements are slower it
doesn't detract from the impact at all
as it allows us to build anticipation
for every hit and gives us a proper
sense of scale
this scene is absolutely legendary in
anime history and deservingly so it lays
to rest the story arc for one of the
most iconic characters in anime
executing it beautifully with animation
that still stands out to this day and i
certainly can't think of a better way to
send off a video about fight scenes
than with this one
[Music]
and that's all i had time to cover today
again thanks to nano and also bakashi
for helping me research and also write
this video but if there's one thing
junior's video has taught me is that
there are a whole load of scenes and
elements i want to talk about in anime
that are not strictly fight scenes so
i'll probably have to make more videos
like this in the future and for the last
time thank you very much to naruto
online for sponsoring this video
i've talked about the game enough so i
will leave it all up to you to click on
the link in the description and sign up
if you wish it'll support the channel
and if they are happy with it as well we
could possibly make more videos like
this in the future
which would be great now if you're also
one of those people who clicked on a
fight video complains that there was a
guy actually talking about the flights
instead of just mindlessly showing them
go [ __ ] yourselves
hey guys hope you liked the video if you
enjoyed this video then you would
probably like my previous anime fights
video which you can see on the left
or you can also check out some of my
other stuff too and as always if you
want to keep updated on my latest doings
you can follow me on facebook and
twitter anyway that's it for me this
time i've been giggup and i'll see you
all
next time